here's the basics you get three wishes  they must begin with rubbing the lamp  and saying I wish got it think so Rush's  I can't make anybody love anybody or  bring anybody back from the dead  the crowd goes wild Disney's 11 so how  does it work though  so with the instruction rated PG May  24th who's the girl  she's a princess Oh aren't they all know  we've had a connection but she has to  marry him Prince back up boy I need some  room to work  I made you to look like a prince on the  outside but I didn't change anything on  the inside or inside li got you to the  door do you trust me what did you say  but Aladdin has to open it do you trust  me  [Music]  sometimes princess you just have to take  a risk  [Music]  you